all right okay ready okay I guess we're
on the air now if you can call it that
this is jocelyn kaiser at science
magazine and I'm a writer here and today
I'm going to moderate a chat with two
experts on the topic of genomic privacy
the topic the question we're asking is
can we keep our genome secret and one
reason we're holding this discussion is
because of a kind of controversy that
came up about a month ago over the
publication of the genome for a a sucks
cell line used widely in research it
came from a woman with cancer many years
ago whose name is Henrietta Henrietta
Lacks and the researchers who published
her genome did not ask her family if
they for permission to do what they just
did it and that car has a huge amount of
concern because people know where that
those cells came from and they felt that
their they should have been consulted in
there I don't know if they felt their
privacy been invaded that they felt like
it was wrong not to ask the family's
permission so we're going to talk about
that and also the more general topic of
genome privacy because there have been
an increasing number of studies that
have found that when a genome is posted
online in some sort of database for
researchers to use even though it's
supposed to be anonymous there are ways
to figure out where that um whose genome
it is and so one of our experts is one
of our experts is Yun of air lock at the
Whitehead Institute who's a geneticist
and has published a paper in science
recently about how he could identify
these anonymous genomes using public
information is that right no no does
that yes yeah that's a great deduction
Thank You jaslene okay and then our
other guest is misha angrist who is also
a geneticist but really works in the
policy area now and he's a Duke
University and he is one of the people
who have chosen to make their genome
public through George churches
Personal Genome Project so his genome
was out there for the world to see and
we'll hear his thoughts about why he did
that and whether other people would want
to do that um so for our first question
I was going to ask and maybe this is
more for me sure as a policy guy if you
could sort of sum up why the HeLa genome
was so controversial I mean it was a lot
of this information was out there
already right so why is there such a big
deal this time um well I think the the
main reason is because of Rebecca's
glutes wonderful book The Immortal Life
of Henrietta Lacks which um you know I
teach every year and recommend highly um
you know it's interesting the way this
whole sort of story played out I think
first of all it's important to say that
this was not Henry and Alexa's genome
this was the genome of the cell line
from her cervical tumor which has now
been around on earth for more than 60
years and as even from what it was 60
years ago based on my reading of the
paper is in all likelihood it looks
quite different maybe i can i can i can
comment on that maybe i forgot to say
something very important which is that
we're taking questions online on the
website or science live so if i if
anyone's listening and they want to ask
questions please please type in your
questions at the bottom of the science
live box okay we shot back to let me
look let me continue I only wanted to
say something so go ahead yeah yes so
this is a part of think of the of the
unfortunate part of this story so the
the group that published the genome part
of the press release they claimed that
because the genome it's a cancer genome
added it has been around for such a long
time it'd be really hard to
in fair if the mutations in these
genomes belong to the germline variation
in henrietta lacks or a part of the
cancerous and the cell line a process
right but what we and others showed that
you can quite easily infer for the
common variants if they belong to
Henrietta Lacks or or two to the cancer
genome in fact what if you know if I
make and just share it with you right
now so let's see I try to show my screen
and hopefully it will work m.c so can
can you see this another Union battery I
can see it but it's small is it more I'm
trying to make his knowledge you can
have fun a people watching okay so so
what what what I will just say basically
that we took henrietta lacks the
published results by this group her
genome and we cluster it with a thousand
other genomes from that were published
white and what we found was that we can
replicate and we can infer that this
genome the cancerous genome has African
American ancestry despite it is a cancer
genome that was mutated for more than 50
years so the basic information about the
common variants is there and you can
still learn things about Henrietta Lacks
using using a dyslexic west genome yes
and I was not I was not implying
otherwise um I think uh the thing about
the Henrietta the HeLa genome that was
so troublesome was just the fact that
what this family went through is now so
widely known that this seemed like an
opportunity to on for scientists to
behave differently with respect to them
so there's a guy named Joe pickerel who
said you know actually
the population geneticists who said you
know actually the HeLa genome has been
available for many years and of course
you could make the argument that just
the very easy accessibility of the cell
line has made her genome available since
DNA sequencing has been available um but
I think what really sticks in people's
cross including mine is um not that
there was some legal injustice done to
the Lacks family by publishing a HeLa
genome but it was just um it was just
rude and and unnecessary and after all
they've been through in the sort of slow
acknowledgment of who she was that
obviously happened much faster once
Rebecca Rebecca salutes book was
published you know this was there were
there were no excuses anymore to say
well we didn't know that they would care
um or we didn't know who they were yeah
so I think missions point is you know is
very interesting and I think you know
first of all I think that the group that
publish the genome are good scientist
and they had good intentions at the end
they didn't want to offend anyone but I
think what Misha illuminates over here
is this that is a scientist we don't
think a lot about bioethics becomes like
okay we have this genome what like we
focus on the technical challenges and
sometimes we forget that they are human
behind is you know the material that we
are processing right well you know one
thing I made me wonder is uh right now
with someone volunteers to be part of a
research project in their genome is
sequence right and they signed they
signed an informed consent form that
says they know it will be maintained it
will be anonymous but um there's a
chance that someone could put on somehow
identify the person but what I'm
ordering is should they have to get
their relatives consent to to have their
genome sequence should well just be part
of this um well as far as I'm concerned
the short answer is no and I think the
only possible exception to that is if
you're an identical twin so we actually
had a pair of identical twins who wanted
to enroll in the Personal Genome Project
and one twin was game and the other
wasn't and we basically said you either
both have to be in or you're both out
simply because you know that is
one-to-one identifiability in that case
I think for relatives uh it's it's a
tough call to make and in some
probabilistic sense the fact that my
genome is online makes my family more
identifiable than it otherwise would be
and probably in you know in young Apes
hands would be a piece of cake to Rhea
denta Phi my relatives um but I think
you know we then get into this kind of
endless spiral of what we are going to
demand of researchers and participants
and participants family members so you
know if I have a family history of
something of Alzheimer's disease or
heart disease and I disclose that then
aren't I also
I'm revealing something about my family
that maybe they would rather I not share
um so I'm I'm less interested in setting
up roadblocks for family members and
more interested in encouraging families
to have these conversations and for us
to maybe treat this information as less
stigmatizing okay um well I want to talk
about that some more but um I wanted to
ask Jana and maybe you could try again
with the slide what you were trying to
show us before get it to work but how
easy is it to to figure out who an
anonymized you know who that person is
yes so we did you know there are several
studies in the field about it and it
seems that the tank message that all
these studies say that it's easier than
you think now I don't want to say that
it's easy enough that you know my mother
or my cousin that are not geneticists
can do it tomorrow but there are more
and more enabling tools and more and
more data out there that if you are
technologically savvy enough you can
start doing that now if you want we can
have a demonstration over here how we
can identify craig Venter from his
genomic sequence did something like mine
people who crave and rest yeah so so
craig Venter am you know he led the
celerra a genome project he sequences on
genome i think it was out in 2006 so be
sure with the entire ward is on genome
and as an exercise to show how we can be
part of our study that was published in
science a few months ago we took several
people that decided to share like like
misha decided to share the genome with
their full identify ters and to see if
we can recover their identity and one of
whom was a one of them was craig Venter
so what we can do so maybe I tried again
to share my screen
and so what you see can you see this
screen right now that I'm very small
very small that's unfortunate me try to
do it again with a different technique
how about now we can see it it's a
browser with google okay so i'm not sure
if you cannot see there is no maybe
point to do that process so what did he
I just talk about it I mean what
databases did you yeah sure and what did
you find out about himself I mean you
found out who he was I guess from yeah
so basically the process that we know so
first of all our whole project was
inspired by a case of a child was 15
year old child that was conceived by
anonymous sperm donation and this child
in a he sent his own DNA to Family Tree
DNA a recreational genetic genealogy
service and they genotyped markers on
his Y chromosome and then they upload it
to the database and this the company
they try to find matches for you and
suddenly if when you look at the
database he just wanted to know that his
ancestry but when you look at the
database he found a match to two
individuals with almost the same surname
with one Spelling a difference between
them and then he thought that you know
you're not maybe this is a surname of my
father so when you purchase a sperm you
also get some biographical details like
the birthday of your father the hospital
that he was born and so on so they took
all the details including the surname to
a company called only trace this is a
private detective company they gave them
all the details and often and pay some
some money and after two weeks they
returned a name of someone that was born
in this hospital the birth record of a
guy that when we saw spit out the same
day the same surname and he conducted
this guy and apparently this is his
biological father so this was kind of
like a one one incident one that
reported in the literature in them lay
media and we thought we saw to do
a systematic study with thousands of
genomes to see what is the is this
something it's an outlier or this is
something common and what we found that
that for twelve percent of us white
males for middle and upper class we can
correctly infer their surname using this
process the wait I'm confused because
what you described with that boy
conceived using sperm donation right it
sounded like it was mostly traditional
detective work they knew where someone
was born and their birth date I guess
and then they tracked more traditional
methods to tracking down is that right
yes yes so we wanted to see first can I
do that using online tools without being
a private detective can I invited it one
piece of information that was important
is the surname because surname if you
know the center of someone you reduce
the search space in United space united
states by factor of five of five
thousand okay so if i know the surname
of someone from searching 150 million
males and go down to forty thousand the
two to 40,000 miles we're gonna get
Smith what sorry yeah most of it I'm you
don't gets me if most of the surnames
are very uncommon okay so basically what
a what is so we wanted to do this this
study and we showed that first we can
share the sternum correctly of twelve
percent of us white males for middle and
upper class using this process so now i
have just a surname right there are
40,000 people this is the that would
match such a surname but then you know
that according to the HIPAA Privacy Rule
if you have the if you H and the state
are not considered identifiers that you
need to protect so we thought okay what
would happen if I now combine the age in
the state and we did some simulations
using the census data and it is if you
have the age in the state you're getting
down to 12 individuals in most of the
or less now when you have 12 individuals
you can just call them and ask you
participate in a genetic study and to
prove this point we first we look at
craig Venter and we show that we found
his genome we can vary surname and then
if we combine his age and his state we
can get to two people with the same
profile and also we took families from
the thousand genomes and we show that in
this fabric we didn't know their their
identity but using this process we could
identify these families and in the end
we could identify close to 50 people
using this process from the thousand
genome okay and then you would narrow it
down further by know what do these
people they got I know like exactly who
is this person I could get this is
facebook profile if I want it you're
saying you identified 50 unique people
yeah starting is only publicly available
genome information ok I got it now I
want to move on to a question from a
reader which i think is an important
question is from st. Simon and Andrew
and he's asking on what are the future
concerns a possible discrimination of
finding bad genes in someone's genome
that makes sense be sure you don't you
want to take that well I you know
genetic discrimination um I just talked
about this with my class yesterday uh
genetic discrimination in the United
States in so far as we know is not
common but all of survey data especially
that done by the genetics and Public
Policy Center in Washington says that
people are worried about it and so this
had a lot to do with the long tortuous
journey of the genetic information on
nation act AKA gina through Congress
sentence eventual and vegetables pitcher
into law by president bush the younger
in 2008 so if the question is what are
the future concerns about detecting bad
genes yeah is that right yeah that was
the question i mean what what an
consequences of it I thought you have a
I don't know what how you define a bad
gene but I think you're getting at it
with potential discrimination from
insurance companies in four years well
so i can tell you a story um there's a
name Robert Greene who used to be a beat
you and how at Harvard and was in a row
holla gist and retrained as a geneticist
and he's been studying the effects of
disclosing people's uh April lipoprotein
e alleles to initially he started with
first-degree relatives of people with
Alzheimer's disease so a PO he is the
most important genetic risk factor for
garden-variety late-onset Alzheimer's
disease and if you have too bad copies
of this gene then your risk for
developing Alzheimer's is raised
something like 10 to 15 fall hopefully
depending on your gender and ethnicity
etc and so he described I telling giving
a talk to the long-term care insurance
society or association or whatever their
professional organization is and he said
I thought they were going to stone me on
because of course this is what we call
information asymmetry if I know that I'm
at risk for something and the insurance
company doesn't that I'm going to adjust
my insurance consumption accordingly so
if maybe if I don't have any bad apoe
alleles I might lighten up on my
long-term care insurance if I have two
bad copies and it's likely that I oh
hell of Alzheimer's then I would be wise
I can get away with it not to disclose
that to the insurance company so for
whatever reason the insurance companies
have not really be embraced genetics
because probably because there really
aren't many italy's in the world that is
common variants that are still important
for chronic disease that are that are
predictive well write that gets us so oh
that's a long way of saying we don't
know what's going to happen don't you
start to think about pulling risk of the
way countries like Canada um we missed
part of that because it was what were
you saying about Canada I don't know if
that answered the question you're both
sort of frozen um I think you're
inventing this is the only one who's
president I don't know what this person
yeah Justin can I comment on on that you
know also yeah so I think undo this
question is no it's interesting the way
that you phrase it you know bad gene
what is exactly bed and and so I the
thing you know what we found you know
from from empirical research and also
personal stories that
information means different things for
different people right so i did also
personal story that that i have so i am
my ancestors Ashkenazi Jews and i found
out using a recreational genealogy
testing that my maternal line was
recently migrated from Africa phone
right and this is a talk abouts I think
500 years ago so the mother of my mother
and so on so the first two so my mother
called my grandmother a scare you know
what's going on and she said oh this is
like wrong results so I tested with
another company and again they my
mitochondria says that um my maternal
line was recently out from of Africa and
I talked with my mother about it and she
was you know she said you know what
maybe this is something that we want to
keep in the family or something like
that because in Judaism the you know
your status determined by your maternal
line and of course as you see first I'm
not honoring their okay what my mother
asked me and but but i want to emphasize
over here that it it means different
things for different people from I
didn't mean it didn't change anything
that I feel about my ancestry or
something like that or it just was just
very interesting point about my history
but was not something to hide but for my
mother it's something that all this is
like something very unexpected for her
so this is part of the things you know
that it can mean different is also this
the way that and rephrase the question
was very interesting this notion of of
bed it's not just about medical
information it's also about your
ancestry the relationship that you have
with other people and and and so on I'm
gonna ask another question from a reader
named you know she's asking how can we
encourage public participation if we
can't guarantee privacy what will it
take to gain public's trust yeah and
today so I I think you know so i guess
michelle is going to talk about more
about the bioethical side of it so let
me talk about about the technical
aspects of it so there have been several
ways that we try to protect genetic data
including stripping or stripping off the
identifiers masking the data pulling the
data
and an introducing some random noise and
unfortunately none of these strategies
worked and we are sure that they can
they can protect the data I think one
venue that hasn't explored enough is a
home orphic encryption this is a type of
encryption that allows you to do secure
computations without a loosening the
privacy of the genetic information and
there is some work it's in still the
infancy the show that you can actually
do these things that you can still do
some computation you can analyze genomes
without really losing the privacy of the
participants and I think this is a very
interesting research directions for the
field to explore and to see if we can
really materialize that into a more
amends to approach for genetic analysis
okay so there may be technical ways to
better job of protecting data now if we
shouldn't talk about as you said through
bioethical side promising you know kate
is gonna remain accomplished sure well
um I think part of it is to try to think
about the risks and benefits of
participating in research in a different
way so there was actually an article in
the time in the New York Times recently
and I think the headline was something
like we all claim to cherish our privacy
but our keystrokes tell a different
story and in fact I was thinking about
this not 30 minutes ago or an hour ago
when i logged on to this hangout for the
first time and google posts all of these
things that one is supposed to do and
not do and that one recognizes you know
that this is going to wind up on youtube
and will be broadcast far and wide and
of course you know in all of these
things whether it's 23andme or
giving your credit card number to Amazon
there are these terms of use agreements
and almost none of us read them or take
them seriously so um I'm not convinced
that we really are any less cavalier
with our genetic information and I'm not
convinced that we should be less
cavalier but of course that's a value
judgment that's my own personal opinion
I think people should have the option to
do whatever they can do whatever they
want to do and I think young Eve hinted
at this and that there are a number of
people in the field like sat koranyi at
Harvard who have done a lot of work on
tiered consent um and Sharon Terry at
genetic Alliance who I will see here at
the sage meeting tomorrow has developed
a genetic disease registry that allows
very granular control of privacy on
based on the participants wishes but let
me just really get the question by
mentioning this protocol I saw as a
member of the IRB a couple of weeks ago
and you know it was for a new study of
some sort of genetic I disease and the
risks and benefits included a litany of
risks that were attached to genetic
information and the take-home message
was because of all of these risks were
not going to give participants back
anything on because the information is
just too dangerous and too scary and
this really struck me
as well first it struck me as something
I see all too often in research
protocols and it really to me
exemplifies a missed opportunity for
people who do research with human beings
to actually engage with those people to
have an ongoing relationship with them
and to actually say to them yes you were
nice enough to give me your tissue and
all of your medical data and in return I
am going to share with you what I've
learned and I'm not just going to send
you a newsletter I'm not going to give
you some sort of aggregate account of
all the wonderful discoveries were
making but I'm actually going to say
something that I learned about your
genome or your phenotype so I think that
is a way to mitigate people's fears
about loss of privacy and say you know
if you are willing to give a little bit
and relinquish this idea that your data
has to be kept behind a barbed wire
fence then I can actually tell you
something that I've learned about you in
the course of doing research you know
maybe you're hinting at this a little
bit and what you said but I mean sure
Don I know keep some experts have said
we should not be saying that your copier
information is going to stay
confidential we can tell you will do my
best to keep it confidential but we
can't guarantee is that what people are
starting to do or our consent forms yes
well I think that's something that's
really motivated by institutions trying
to limit their own liability because if
they you know make guarantees and
something else comes to pass
they will get sued so you know of course
yaniv mentioned HIPAA before so HIPAA
says if you remove this list of 18
things from the data then the data is no
longer considered to be human subjects
data and so that gives the researcher
much more latitude and so that's a very
strong incentive to keep the data secret
and that's something that the Personal
Genome Project and these other sort of
participatory research initiatives have
had to struggle with which is to say we
don't actually want the data
de-identified or anonymized because we
think it's more valuable and certainly
more interesting to the participant if
we can keep in touch with that person
right well I want to bring up another
question maybe llanes can go first you
so you both have had your genomes
sequenced right and what I'm wondering
is if a genome genotype lock sequence
you detect okay but I'm wondering what
are people afraid of I mean what is an
art we mentioned a couple of examples
like that you believe gene and maybe
your ancestry but really um you know is
these are charged genomes really that
interesting I have to say Misha I looked
at yours briefly and you know it didn't
blow me away I didn't seem to me like
there was anything to jail it's
fascinating I'm not a scientist III
think you know so the question I think
it's context-dependent right and
basically it's like this information and
part of our role as scientists is to
educate the public about you know what
you can do and cannot do with genomes
what does it mean was it but it doesn't
mean your genome but i think its context
dependent and I think for different
people in different times the different
ethnic group it can be something you
know we some people can be stigmatized
wait some people can be can be
problematic for them but I won't really
trade i want to emphasize the point that
misha said before about the benefits so
you asking what what are they how we can
ensure that people keep participating in
studies we should also talk about the
benefits not just about the risks that
we have in genetic studies and you know
just in in my lab together with Hadassah
Medical Center in Israel we discovered
two genes for devastating disorders in
in ashkenazi jews and palestinians and
we could not do this process we could
not do these studies without public data
sharing by people like like misha and
this is something that you know by these
studies we could give hope for families
for parents so we should also talk about
the benefits of genetic studies and but
we should keep monitoring the situation
keep monitoring how easy is it is to
identify people offer the safeguards
other societies societies safeguards
legal safeguards technical safeguards
but keep you know illuminate keep
repeating these benefits from the
studies yeah oh I think you're Nev is
exactly white and you know I'm part of a
group that's doing whole exome
sequencing of families with sick babies
this idea that was first a sort of
brought to light a few years ago by
Howard Jacob and his colleagues at the
medical university of medical college of
wisconsin and in fact there are a number
of groups doing this sort of thing and
obviously for a child with devastating
likely genetic condition the family is
interested in knowing what the causative
variant is um but you know what they're
also interested in knowing everything
else and so far we've been somewhat
hamstrung from giving back the
other stuff and so we are having to
negotiate all of these new relationships
and this blurring of the line between
what is research what is clinical
medicine and it's been a real challenge
it's been a real institutional challenge
okay um at this point we don't have a
whole lot more questions so if you guys
want to say something to kind of wrap up
and then take it away any drinking
everything how to wrap up and you know
just to summarize this conversation so
you know I am basically did the chat why
did the title was can we keep our genome
secret right and the and I think I will
rephrase it do we want to keep our
genome secret and how we can do that
right and I think you know I think so
the focus kind of like of this jet was
about the risks that we have and I think
we kind of like we summarize you know we
went from the technically how is it how
is it is to identify personal genomes we
talked about a different maybe technical
bioethical safeguards for that and I
think you know I would wrap it up but
talking about the benefits that we have
for genetic research for society and she
keep remembering that it's not only
about the risks that we have um I would
say this are you know this idea of
personalized medicine frankly that the
phrase has become a cliche on what we
would talk about it all the time we
talked about how you know when we give
someone a drug we can have a
one-size-fits-all sort of approach and I
think what I and the people i tend to
hang out with are pushing for is why
can't
we have the same sort of nuanced
individual approach to genetic and
genomic and informational privacy in
general so someone as you Nev said one
person may feel stigmatized one person
may feel like they don't want to share a
particular allele most famously Jim
Watson did not want to have his apoe
genotype made public I think that's
unfortunate given who he is in the world
but I respect his choice and I don't
think you know just because I chose to
make my genome public I would never
presume to tell anyone what to do with
their own a medical or genomic or
metabolomic or any sort of information
about their own biology I think they
should have the option to treat it as
privately or as publicly as they see fit
and I would like to see institutions
find ways to accommodate that right okay
all right well I want to thank you both
very much for chatting with us today and
thank you and as for our readers where
we will have another chat coming up I
think next week i'm not sure what the
topic is so please come back and visit
us next week at this time thanks Jocelyn
thank you so much bye-bye well